Một ai thương bà đại xưa Iran tại cơ quan nâng lộng huynh tư của tế Air Region, Najafi,
chứ biết, cơ sở hạp nhân tăng giới bị đánh chung trong các họ đồng quân sự gần đây của
Mình và Israel đồng thường nhân mạnh đây là cơ sở hạp nhân dân sự đang chữ giám xác
cơ tế, tuy nhiên tổng giám nốc Air Air Ura-File Grosy, cho biết, cơ quan này chưa có bằng chứng sắc nhận
việc cơ sở hạp nhân quý và bị hạp hạy là bị đánh chung, trong thời chứ biết thêm,
liên lạc với cơ quan quà liên, như li vàng bạng đang đường nối lạc.
I Air Air đã trữ tập viên họ bất vường bị tình hình tại Iran, bắt tình bóng huy cơ giòn dị phóng sạch không thể bị rạch
chưa, niếu các cơ sở hạp nhân bị tánh cơng, bởi hộ quà có tình nghiêm trọng và vừa trang hoài bịn rửi.
Cơ quan này cho biết chưa ki nhận nốc phóng sạch ra tăng tại các nước lắng dìa, sau mặt lối sám sẽ khu bự đã đuất đặt trong tình trạm cạnh sắc cao.
Phu không kích qua lại vẫn còn tiếp dẫn, tổng nguy cơ lớn đối khả nâng dòng dị phóng sạch nhân chứ bất cảnh Israel
T'é ran phủ nhận và khẳng lệnh chương trình hấp nhận nhằm một bếc qua bình.